where can someone begin to cultivate
more of these characteristics that could
you know lead them in a better direction
as you all know you know folks like
hberman talking about it but you know
the neuroplasticity of the mind right
you can change the wiring in your brain
and I just view it like a muscle that
needs working out H and you can change
the composition of that one of the most
defining moments for me in my sport was
when Simon taught me about the anterior
singulate cortex that sits behind the
eyes and it monitors um emotional and
physical pain and it actually as it
experiences adversity it grows and gets
denser I mean that that's kind of a
rudimentary sense of it so for me it was
like okay so if I do harder things it's
going to get bigger so then I can cope
with more harder things oh that makes
sense so then I need harder things to do
it's almost like homework to work in it
cuz we work on our bodies but we don't
work on our brain